In the name of the Father, and of the Son, and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 20th, on which we commemorate the Holy Haramarder
Anastasios II, patriarch of Antioch.
This second Saint Anastasios, a monk and perhaps the abbot of Mount Sinai, succeeded the first
Saint Anastasios immediately after his blessed death in the year 599.
A vigilant pastor, he undertook to reform the conduct of his people, and pronounced several
discourses against the Jews, who since the beginning of the 6th century, had revolted
several times in Syria and Palestine, going as far as completely to destroy the city of
Cessaria.
After severe repressions, the emperor of Falkas tried to impose baptism on the Jews of Antioch
in the year 609, a measure which provoked an insurrection and led to the capture of Saint
Anastasios by the rebels.
After killing and vile mutilating him, they tied his body to a rope, and dragged it through
the city, finally throwing it into a fire.
After the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.